my opponent tonight is running for
re-election in Vermont's against what I
could only assume as a Subaru filled
with maple syrup senator Bernie Sanders
oh you you have said that this upcoming
midterm election might be the most
important election in our lifetimes that
is what I said now people say this over
and over again
politicians have said this year in and
year out you can't just keep saying
something over and over again assuming
people are going to believe it
winch shut witch hunt why is this the
most important midterm because we have
the worst president in the history of
the United States at least admit to him
being the best at being the worst
all right I'll grant should thank you
and that it is imperative that we end
one-party rule in Washington where
Republicans control the White House the
Senate and the house nope okay
it's 2018 about impeaching the president
know what 2018 is about is for a start
paying attention to the needs of working
families in this country stopping an
agenda which wants to throw up to 32
million people off of the health care
they have make massive cuts to Medicare
Medicaid Social Security disability
education and environmental protection
all the while giving a billion dollars
in tax breaks to the top 1%
this election is a mild among other
things stopping that agenda okay well
tell me this don't look at me I got a
tax cut look at her look at me I'm good
it's gonna be all right Jesus
now what would you say you know what I'm
say what I'm saying is I'm a happy guy
all right all right good
I got a tax cut good four percent
unemployment there's a burger joint in
Pyongyang why do I want the Republicans
out of us well I think you want them out
of office for a number of reasons I
think the agenda of giving tax breaks to
billionaires and cutting programs for
people who are living in desperation is
not what this country is about I think
moving toward an authoritarian form of
government where you have a president
who is a pathological liar
he's a theory he is creative in his lies
I do grant you that but their lies
nonetheless and I think most
significantly this country has struggled
with bigotry for several hundred years
now and we have made some progress in
recent times and to have a president who
is trying to divide us up based on the
color of our skin or a gender or a
religion or the country we came from
that is not what this country is about
and we cannot allow that to continue
we're gonna disagree on the way in which
we see the president but you obviously
want you don't like what he stands for
and at a midterm that you see it as this
important when you're looking at
candidates on the Left is this is this
the midterm where you don't support that
progressive who might not have a chance
of winning and you support the more
moderate what has a chance to win you
know what I when I ran for president but
isn't that isn't that about what's
important right now is that four years
ago we had the lowest voter turnout in
this country since World War two lowest
voters are about 37% what's important
now is that ordinary people young people
get involved in the political process
they vote they run for office they
demonstrate and they stand up for
American values and we're beginning to
see that all over this country people
running and winning for the will running
for the very first time do you think
there's any tactical move though for the
Democratic Party should they be focused
on those candidates who can win should
they be focused on one specific issue as
opposed to just being anti Donald Trump
right now they cannot just be anti
Donald Trump what they have got to be is
talking to the needs of working families
we are the only major country on earth
not to guarantee health care to all
people a majority of the American people
think that's wrong let's move forward
Medicare for all we got millions of
people right now I'm going to California
literally tomorrow to talk to people are
working at Disneyland one of the most
profitable cord is Lee is one of the
most profitable corporations in America
these people don't earn enough money to
pay for an apartment some of them are
living in tents so what we need to do is
raise the minimum wage the 15 bucks an
hour instead of giving tax breaks to
billionaires we got a demand that they
stop paying their fair share of taxes
you have a bill you are pushing this
idea that that would guarantee every
American a job that pays at least $15 an
hour whatever happened this idea of
pulling yourself up by your bootstraps
what do you have that's a great idea
except it really is not working in
America today we're seeing relatively
little mobility if you're an
african-american kid of a wealthy parent
for example the likelihood of you making
it to the top is less than if you're
white working-class kid the truth is
right now that economic mobility is
fairly stagnant the rich are getting
richer the middle class are struggling
we got 40 million people living in
poverty we got hundreds of thousands of
kids can't afford to go to college
because of lack of income and we've got
many people in this country who leave
school 30 50 $100,000 in debt that
frankly is insane
so our job and this is what we got to do
we got to create a government that
thoughts working for all people not just
wealthy campaign contributors that's
what this campaign is about
all people corporations are people too
and I don't know if they'd be so hot on
some of these ideas here is this just
for show about Jordan you raise a very
important point yeah and that is as a
result of this disastrous citizens
united Supreme Court decision allowing
corporations to spend as much money as
they want on elections we are saying the
undermining of American democracy you're
seeing one family the Koch brothers
planning to spend up to four hundred
million dollars in this midterm election
that is not what democracy is about
that's what oligarchy is about and
that's what we're fighting you gotta
spend money to make money for me I mean
we have more to talk about when we come
back we'll be back for more with Bernie
Sanders over the break we were talking
and some pretty big news you told me
you're running for president in 2020 for
reelection in Vermont to the United
States Senate that's something there has
been talk your former campaign manager
Jeff Weaver this week said you're
considering it well consider a lot of
things but that decision the focus right
now is on 2018 2020 as a way away and
we'll make that decision at the
appropriate time like I'm on the other
side but I love the idea of you running
if you can help divide the Democratic
Party I'd be all about that no no no let
me say a word about that oh the truth is
there is less division of among the
American people
and certainly within the Democratic
Party than people think for example do
people think we should give tax breaks
to billionaires overwhelming opposition
people are unified or not the people
believe we should have sensible gun
safety legislation vast majority the
American people believe in that
two people believe that women should
earn the same amount of money doing the
same work as men overwhelming support
for that if you really go down that the
people believe that climate change is
real how you destroy now I know I know
you and the Donald think it's a hoax
emanating from China I got it yeah but
there are some of us who disagree with
that suggestion there are critics even
in the Democratic Party who say having
people like you in charge the face of
the Democratic Party or at least of the
progressives that it's time for younger
people to step on up young youthful
disgusting are you suggesting that I am
NOT a young voice for the number of
Bernie I'm saying they're young voices
out there like Joe Biden who you're
right you're right here's the thing
Bernie in case you decide to run I want
to help okay and so I have a couple
slogans that I thought I'd like to to
show you to see if I'm okay then what do
you have here Bernie for presidents I
can speak to birds that's a window
Sanders aligned with Trump on more than
you'd think
no no not a winner Bernie something
about millionaires and billionaires all
right we'll take up one two out of three
Nellie that was not bad not bad I don't
know all the details it feels like it
just has a quip II right yeah tell me
this birdie there's a lot of talk about
Donald Trump and you you go after him a
lot North Korea if he sits down
if he gets kim jeong-hoon to sit down
they talk nobel prize for that B's and
fun but no no well it is it's about
actually it's a serious issue North
Korea is a very isolated authoritarian
regime which has nuclear weapons and I
think in any way in every way possible
anything that we can do to rid the world
of that danger is a step forward and if
Trump can pull it off that's a good
thing what actions has it where is the
country heading in the right direction
where do you think we're pointed well I
think obviously after the terrible Wall
Street recession when millions of people
lost their jobs and their homes and
their life savings because of the greed
and illegal behavior of Wall Street we
have been recovering the fact the entire
world economy has been recovering so the
degree that unemployment is low today
that's obviously a good thing the
problem however is that many of the jobs
being created are not paying a living
wage and the younger generation
everything being equal unless we change
it well how the lowers standard of
living than their parents that's wrong
so our goal now is not only a full
employment economy it's to create an
economy where people earn living wages
to create an economy where you're not
punished for getting a higher education
by leaving school deeply in debt
creating an economy which exists all
over the industrialized world where
health care is a right not a privilege
Bernie Sanders tell me something I
already know
Oh what you already know is your great
shock and concern that three people in
our country own more wealth than the
bottom half of the American people and I
know that you share with me your deep
concern about that level of income and
wealth inequality your socialism goes so
deep we're sharing concern know as well
unbelievable
senator Bernie Sanders
[Music]